Sal alarri was one of hamas's top
officials he was meeting other leaders
from the group in the bayut suburb of
dahia when a huge explosion destroyed
the building he'd been a target of
Israel and its allies for
years and though Israel did not
officially take credit for the
assassination it was the latest in a
long line of targeted killings of Hamas
leaders alarri is believed to have been
one of the founders of hamas's armed
Wing the Kasam brigades the US state
department had a $5 million bounty on
his head since at least
2015 as hamas's second in command he was
known to be a top Israeli
Target another person sure to be on
Israel's most wanted list is this man
he's Yaya sinoa leader of Hamas in Gaza
and the person Israel holds most respons
responsible for the attacks on October
7th prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu
calls sinoa a dead man
walking Israel has been killing Hamas
figures for decades the group's Founders
shikh Ahmed Yasin and Abdul aiz alantis
were assassinated in 2004 dozens of
other Hamas commanders and leaders have
met similar Fates over the years part of
a wider campaign against several
Palestinian groups there's a sense that
they can kind of weaken the Palestinians
um and eliminate their leaders and keep
them kind of defeated and divided but
you know we've seen that that those
policies those violent policies haven't
worked in you know in suppressing
Palestinian General desire for freedom
from
occupation after the October 7th attacks
and the death of more than a thousand
Israelis mostly civilians Israel seems
to no longer be willing just to blockade
Hamas in and pick off its leaders its
stated aim is now the group's complete
destruction considering them legitimate
targets no matter where they are one
analyst says the attack could lead to
retaliatory strikes against Israel
globally Jewish communities all over the
world Israeli embassies will be targeted
um we know that Hamas andah can do it
and uh I think that this is opening a
new circle of Violence new
escalation with the death toll in Gaza
topping
22,000 Palestinians they may feel
they're all on Israel's kill list M
lappel El
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer